die haben mich wirklich nur sechs
minuten zeit gekostet leute super
also ich find das leckerer ist das erste
gerade ich weiß ich werde jetzt mal so
leckere weckten jazziges
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es drei
pasta rezepte von mir weil oft weiß man
nicht was soll ich heute kochen und man
muss schnell schnell machen man hat
nicht viele zutaten und daher gibt es
heute wirklich drei super einfache
rezepte mit wenig zutaten mit ganz wenig
schnickschnack ich fange direkt an mit
meine asiatisch angehaucht modeln dafür
nehme ich mir guck mal das habe ich hier
noch im kühlschrank gehabt sondern halbe
rote spitze afrika dies ein bisschen
schärfer und die schneide ich jetzt in
ganz ganz ganz feine stückchen dann
werde ich auch noch eine zwiebel obwohl
ich muss anders ich sage heute sehr
spontan ich nehme für dieses rezept nur
frühlingszwiebeln da mache ich so dass
ich das weiß in die pfanne geben zum
dünsten und den rest könnt euch auch
gewarnt und später und topf geben und
bei mir kommt auch noch knoblauch mit
dazu und dass du dann alles in etwas
olivenöl angedünstet und ihr findet die
ganz genaue mengenangaben wie immer
unten in der infobox
[Musik]
so ich hab jetzt nebenbei noch rahmen
gekocht ihr könntet für dieses gericht
auch ganz normale passt annehmen dann
ist die kurze zeit natürlich viel länger
rahmen sind innerhalb von 23 minuten
fertig und ich finde das passt einfach
zum asiatischen flair und die gebe ich
jetzt einfach hier mit in die pfanne und
dann brauchen wir ja noch etwas mehr
geschmack so er was saucen artiges und
da passt halt immer sojasauce ganz gut
dann nehme ich sojasauce außerdem wenn
ihr mögt wo schwester soße und da könnt
ihr einfach gucken wenn ihr keine
rochester so ist da habt könnt ihr auch
esther soße nehmen das ist einfach nur
für die würze und irgendwas süßes
braucht es auch immer da könnt ihr dann
zum beispiel honig nehmen oder agaven
dicksaft david guetta grafiksoftware das
theme pack ich dir noch mit dazu dann
einmal umrühren und dann könnt ihr auch
gerne noch mal abschminken
[Musik]
hanser ich habe sechs minuten nudeln
gemacht schön aber dass nutella seinem
teller heute gibt's ja dreimal nur
deswegen müssen ein bisschen auf die
linie
das ist ja dass im rahmen den die haben
nicht wirklich nur sechs minuten zeit
gekostet leute man kann ja auch pimpen
man kann könnt ihr auch hinten fleisch
oder garnelen oder so doch selber nicht
so genau das macht ganz viel ganz viel
aufwand
sojasauce rochester soße und agaven
dicksaft für die süße der optimismus pur
und typisch chinesisch japanisch
koreanisch keinen blödsinn so aber
vermisst so wird es jetzt einen border
reden wir von diesem fleisch oder gemüse
oder so ich mag super dass du kleines
stück daran zu unterwerfen oder auf den
kanälen wie wenn jemand
gut dann bin ich mal sagen papa nachdem
ein thema und das ist sehr gerne essen
ich mache das nächste rätsel für das
zweite pastagericht koche ich schon mal
nebenbei schmetterlings model also
verfallen und zwar diesmal in salzwasser
gerade bei dem rahmen dudeln braucht nur
noch kein salz wasser liefern brauchen
ist aber und in der zwischenzeit mache
ich hier schon mal eine pesto basilico
sauce mit thunfisch ihr könnt ihr auch
weglassen wenn ihr nicht möchte aber ich
habe ihnen raptor und mag das ganz gerne
ist gebe ich hier einmal die ziele die
habe ich zuvor fein gehackt die gebe ich
hier in meinem kopf hat ist noch
ausgeschaltet da gebe ich jetzt auch
schon knoblauch mit dazu einfach rein
pressen habe ich auch voll nicht
gesäubert hier weil da er sowieso noch
mal knoblauch rein kommt und dann kommt
pesto basilico zum einsatz könnt ihr
selber machen oder wenn es halt so wie
heute schnell gehen soll oder ihr
einfach von der arbeit von der schule
uni et cetera kommt und keine zeit und
keinen nerv neben gutes fertiges pesto
basilico und da ist ja auch schon sehr
viel olivenöl drin verarbeitet daher
brauche ich kein zusätzliches öl und
jetzt schalte ich dem herrn ein und lass
das wirklich so ganz langsam binzen
[Musik]
so die nudeln sind jetzt gar gekocht ich
werde jetzt auch gleich sofort ab gießen
aber vorher brauchen mit ganz ganz
dringend noch das nudelwasser das ist
echt gold wert bei solchen saucen
einfach so ein zweig allen damit rein
tun ich mal eine ich gucke wie sich das
so ja wie die seligkeit ist und da gebe
ich jetzt noch sahne mit dazu das ist
die fettreduzierte genommen die vorfeld
variante nehmen wir können doch milch
nehmen kokosmilch also zu viele
varianten
sondern führe ich das und gäbe da den
thunfisch und die nudeln mit dazu dienen
die sich jetzt aber wie gesagt im
schnell ab
[Musik]
so passt da nochmal 2 gegen auch extrem
schnell das ist pasta mit pesto und das
sieht man kann es keinen fisch aber tun
sich geht das geht immer
[Musik]
lecker wenn man keinen fisch mag kann
man einfach ersatzlos weg lassen man
kann auch hähnchen dazu nehmen einfach
alles so viel strom dass ich nicht nur
schmeckt frisch richtig frisch ich
glaube das ist das
übrigens für den eigenen saft
ich habe jetzt hier fertigen pastor
genommen nachts immer auf bioqualität
auf eine gute qualität und man kann
natürlich auch selber machen jetzt meine
frage du kennst man das gemacht das
pesto findest du jetzt momenten großen
unterschieden klein wir merken
unterschied ist kein großer unterschied
aber also das weckt so mehr dabei sind
wenn du sowas ja schon intensiver sie
also selbst gemacht ist natürlich immer
besser und schnell gehen muss dann nimmt
man einfach den fertigen macht so einen
kleinen abstrich das ist vielleicht
nicht ganz so intensiv schmeckt aber
trotzdem richtig lecker richtig cremig
hat eine richtig tolle konstante so löse
also ich finde dass die ecke da ist das
erste gerade also ich bin erfährt davon
als von diesem von dieser so ja aber
das ist ja noch nicht mal keinen fisch
mag ich sagen wir mal ich hab das meriva
ist so ja das ist ja genau und wenn die
mal gespannt was du dich zu dritten
variante sei fast ein übergang wir
machen nämlich als drittes eine
richtig davon ich liebe leute
eine weitere gruppe das dritte gericht
wird jetzt noch mal so richtig fit point
wir gönnen uns mcinnis aber als auflauf
mit so einer knospe schicht oben drüber
dafür habe ich hier diese ganz kleinen
court nudeln ich habe sie nicht gar
gekocht auch nicht wirklich al dente
also kurz vor al dente ich zeig euch das
mal dann müsst ihr wirklich noch so ein
bisschen was von diesem rudeln in den
sinn ich hoffe ich konnte klären aber
ihr seht ja also die kochen gleich
nochmal im backofen komplett da und das
ist wichtig dass sie nicht so pampig
werden und jetzt mache ich hier die käse
soße dafür nämlich einfach jetzt die
gleiche panne daher brauchen wir butter
und das wird jetzt erst mal verlassen
ich werde jetzt aber auch noch klub auch
schon direkt rein passen nicht zu heiss
gehen mit der hitze butter kann sehr
schnell verbrennen stufe 6 von neuen
reicht vollkommen dann gehen wir mehr
dazu und rühren dass erstmals so dass
eine mehlschwitze entsteht
[Musik]
die mehlschwitze hilft es einfach später
dass die konsistenz perfekt wird und wo
teils natürlich auch geschmacksträger
wichtig ist dass ihr euch also zwei bis
drei minuten zeit gibt auch wirklich auf
mittel hoher geschwindigkeit vertrag auf
mittelbar hitze und es schreiben das
sieht man hier ganz groß
und nimmt auch ein bisschen farbe an und
jetzt geben dem ich mir dazu ganz
wichtig ist stückchenweise also ein
bisschen dazugeben verrühren und
irgendwann merkt ihr dass die masse
einfach wunderbar zusammenhält und dann
könnt ihr auch schon größere stücke dazu
geben
[Musik]
hier fühl mich hier von den käser
gegeben ich nehme gouda und chatter ihr
könnt auch nur gouda unternehmen das das
komplett geschmackssache aber worauf wir
auf jeden fall verzichten sollte sind
meiner meinung nach auf diesen fertig
geriebenen käse der hat ja trennmittel
und wenn ihr das dann dazu jetzt dort in
ewigkeit bis schmilzt und ich finde auch
käse am stück schmeckt einfach viel viel
intensiver war ja mein tipp auf jeden
fall den am stück nehmen lass das jetzt
hier auch nur noch in der rest hitze
schmelzen die reichen nämlich vollkommen
und dann könnt ihr entweder die nudeln
hier mit in den topf geben alles
verrühren und dann in die auflaufform
oder er gibt er 40 in die auflaufform
und gießt dann die hebesätze drüber
angesagt wird ein feuchtes vergessen
hätte ich schon so gut wirken durch das
gleiche nämlich nur noch mit
paprikapulver edelsüß und ein bisschen
gemüsebrühe
[Musik]
wir gehen noch einen schritt weiter ich
habe ja gesagt es gibt noch einen kranz
schicht obendrauf und dafür brauchen wir
jetzt noch ein bisschen butter also das
ist wirklich auch ein gericht ist können
man sich mal das muss man sich jeden tag
essen aber man gönnt sich das entschied
der er oder unserem samstag sonntag
durch die mutter wieder viel zu erlassen
auch vorsicht nichts weiß könnt ihr
prinzipiell auch in der mikrowelle
machen und da gehen wir jetzt an e mail
dazu dass 70 das normale paniermehl
sondern pankofer nehme mir das kennt ihr
schon aus einigen videos von mir was ist
so dieses asiatische fannie mae das ist
viel kantiger viel viel größer und ich
hab einfach besser finde ich gebe ich
jetzt mit dazu wichtig ist nur dass das
pankow paniermehl jetzt zusammen mit der
butter 1 wird also dass ich das wirklich
so vereint und dann könnt ihr entweder
direkt hier auf den auflauf geben oder
ihnen nochmal schritt weiter wenn wir
gesagt wir können uns heute ihr könnt
hier einfach noch mal so eine mischung
aus zelda und gouda den vorher gehabt
und ob geben und dann kommt die
schichtung drauf und dann kommt das
ganze in den backofen den habe ich vor
gehalt auf 180 grad ober und unterhitze
der box die nach dem biss es halt
goldbraun ist entweder zehn oder 15
minuten genau guckt einfach dass es
schön goldbraun ist und dann könnt ihr
euch das können
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der letzte test und ich
glaube auch der beste für heute das ist
wichtig food possible das ist ein käse
pur mit diesem quatsch obendrauf oben
ist pankow fannie mae haben sie haben
wir auch bank open in richtung teil ich
fress dich wirklich sitzen wir so weit
weg ist beginnen ist dass sie nie man
halten was natürlich das gewissen
kalorien aber ganz erlebt man so ist ihr
mann können oder casey stoner honda lisa
chronisch verzichtet nicht drauf nimmt
dieses manko paniermehl das macht
richtig und
lecker aber ich habe es langsam
kohlenhydrate über 5.300 an einem tag
gleich 100 sagte wir haben irgendwie
alles gebiete welche habt heute und ich
würde sagen wenn ihr noch mal so ein
wiedersehen möchte wo wir drei rezepte
von einer allerletzten hatten wir drei
frühstücks rezepte heute 30 der kräfte
was müsst ihr als nächstes sehen
schreibt gerne mal in die kommentare so
meine ich das komplette ansonsten
nachmachen und abonnierten kanal
hinterlassen
[Musik]